We already told you here on visual
politic,
even though it is unusual to hear about
this,
the truth is that in recent years,
some things have begun to change in
Africa.
The year 2000,
half of the fastest growing economies on
the planet have actually been located on
this continent according to the
international monetary funds forecasts
in 2018.
Six.
Yeah,
six of the 10 economies with the highest
growth rates will be African countries
like Tanzania,
Ethiopia in the Ivory Coast or at the
head of the race.
In terms of global growth.
Now,
Africa is a huge continent.
It's made up of 54 individual countries,
so we can find all sorts of situations
here.
Countries that grow a lot and countries
that grow well less,
but there's a case that stands out above
all of them and not precisely because
things are going well.
Yes,
of course.
I'm talking about South Africa or a
country.
That was the great African hope for a
really long time.
Well,
Dvu at the truth is that Nelson
Mandela's dream of a free and prosperous
South Africa.
It's become something of a nightmare.
In recent years,
things have gone really wrong,
growth,
Spanish,
racial problems of returns in corruption
has spread throughout the country.
Congress is actually talking about
expropriating,
the glands of white people without any
compensation.
However,
in February the government changed and
one of the richest men in Africa became
the new presidents.
So could South Africa get back on the
right path or are we facing another
great African disappointments?
In this video,
we also want to look at what caused
those good years to ends and if the
white population in the country faces
any risk,
so let's get on with it.
South African disappointment.
South Africa is a huge country.
It's about the size of France,
Germany,
Italy,
the Netherlands,
and Belgium all combined together and it
represents about a quarter of all of
Subsaharan.
Africa is GDP well after the ends of a
pore size and after the democratic
transition that began in 1994.
South Africa experienced a particular
golden age between 1998 and 2008.
The economy grew steadily.
This allowed the black middle class to
double and essential services such as
running water reached to most of the
relations
with a big economy,
a vibrant democracy,
a free press,
and lots of civic organizations seems
ready for South Africa to make the leap
that would allow its people and not just
white people to live the comfortable
lives of citizens of a developed
country.
In other words,
South Africa was expected to become a
role model for the entire African
continent.
My hold on a moment here because things
don't always turn out quite as expected
and in 2009,
this entire process ended.
Since then,
things have just gone from bad to worse.
Economy isn't growing.
Unemployment has risen to almost 40
percent.
Poverty has picked up again and public
accounts are absolutely shattered and
that's not all the latest government
measures that the government is
announced and the current social
tensions have even caused.
Announcements like this
last March,
2018 Australian Minister of internal
affairs,
Peter Dutton publicly announced that his
country would consider granting a
special emergency visa and refuge to the
South African white population that felt
unsafe in their own country.
Now,
hold on just a moment here because we're
talking about an Australian minister
here talking about sheltering white
South Africans.
I mean all things really that bad.
Wasn't this the country of harmony and
reconciliation?
Well,
you heard what that minister had to say,
but at this point in the question really
still remains.
What the hell went wrong?
Well,
we already have our culprits.
We talked about him before.
By the way,
in a video that I will link to in the
description.
Do you know who he is?
Well,
listen.
Okay.
Jacob Zuma,
ninth of May,
2009,
Jacob Zuma became the president of South
Africa.
Just launched his controversial record,
which included accusations of rape,
corruption,
and even organized crime.
Zuma managed to reach power thanks to
the support of the popular classes who
felt that he was one of their own.
After all,
we're talking about one of the most
prominent leaders of the anti apartheid
movement and leader for 10 years was in
prison with Nelson Mandela himself,
the father of the current South African
nation,
and this well.
It gave him a great deal of credibility.
Worldview.
Jacob Zuma,
who opened the practices polygamy and is
estimated to have at least 20 children,
was forced to resign and leave through
the back door on February the 14th,
2018.
See,
I mean,
check this out.
He was repudiated by his own party,
the powerful African National Congress
cornered by the opposition who
threatened him with a motion of censure.
He simply had no other alternative.
You had to leave one way or another for
the almost nine years that Zuma was
empower.
Life in South Africa was a nightmare.
You see zoom that came to power with the
promise of a more prosperous country and
more opportunities for the poorest,
but instead it's.
Well,
what do you think he did?
Yup.
Nothing less than turning these South
African governments into a kind of mine,
a business that's simply served him and
is in a circle.
By the way,
do you know what the first thing he did
after named president was?
Well,
he spent $23,000,000 from the state
budget to improve his private residence.
That's what we mean pulled here or an
empathy that he even had a cow barn and
a chicken coop built,
but of course that's not all.
On March,
the 16th national prosecutors announced
that they would present challenges
against Jacob Zuma for a multimillion
dollar purchase agreements of weapons
ships,
submarines,
and fighter jets with European companies
that South Africa signs in the 19
nineties.
For this time,
Zuma was Nelson Mandela's deputy
presidents.
This weapons purchase cost over
$3,000,000,000 and the stated goal was
improving national security.
The real goal though was enriching.
Guys like Jacob Zuma,
the arms deal was the most graphic loss
of innocence of post apartheid South
Africa and it Persado the corruption
we're seeing today.
David Lewis,
executive director of corruption.
Watch a nonprofit organization based in
your hand is Berg,
and this is just one case.
Dozens and dozens of more cases are
lined up for Zima,
so in short,
yes,
he was a really,
really greedy dude.
In total is estimated that Jacob Zuma is
corruption and the corruption of his
inner circle have cost the public
coffers more than 4 million American
dollars,
or if you think that is the West thing,
well you all very,
very wrong.
The worst part is that he got the cancer
that is corruption to spread massively
through the country.
Listen up here,
cancer
thing was always clear that Jacob Zuma,
and he even said it openly,
his party,
the national African Congress,
was more important than the very South
African nation that had been elected to
serve and what better way to put the
party in the forefront then by enriching
it's leaders with public resources and
that's precisely what he did have since
Zuma came to power.
Corruption has multiplied.
State services are a mess,
and some math teachers don't even know
what a square root is.
Indeed,
the reason they got the job with simply
because they were formerly affiliated
with the president's party,
virtually no institution in South Africa
has been spared from the corruption,
so you see one way to measure the
intensity of corruption in South Africa
is to look at the quality of housing
that the government builds for its
poorest people.
If the budget is already low,
when we discount what politicians take,
not only in terms of money,
also in construction materials,
in the end,
houses end up so poorly constructed that
some have even collapse.
Another very common form of corruption
is seizing funds that were aimed at the
developments of the poorest areas.
For an example,
we can look at dairy farms that are
backed by the government.
That's okay.
The best case is that of a farm promoted
directly by Moza benzies Wayne,
who of course became zoom as minister of
mining.
So I.
One day this gentleman came to a poor
community and promise to build a dairy
farm that was financed by the
government.
Supposedly the farm would be controlled
by the workers who'd joined the project
and who were even promised a trip to
India to learn how to manage the farm.
So as you can probably see from this
already,
it's not exactly looking great.
He said he wanted to change our lives.
He said this thing was coming from the
government free of charge.
He said,
we couldn't say don't like this thing.
we must take it a frame can Yamini of
black South African farmer.
In the end the government spends more
than $20,000,000,
but the only ones who went on a trip
with,
uh,
members of this politicians church
choir,
and of course he kept any leftover money
as for the farm.
What it is unclear if any cow milks
thanks to this project,
and this again is just one example.
Out of hundreds in recent years,
billions of dollars aimed at
developments have been diverted,
simply lost by the leaders of the ruling
party.
And of course,
as you can imagine,
all of this has caused a huge amounts of
economic damage investing in a country
where any politician can stick his hands
in the coffers or where public accounts
are highly unreliable,
does not sound enticing.
But now off Jacob Zoom is forced
resignation.
His party was getting nervous about the
upcoming elections and the big question
now becomes,
will the new government change things
change
maybe the 15th,
2018.
After Jacob Zoom his resignation,
several roundup posts,
another historic leader of the anti
apartheid movement was named president.
We all talking about just any guy though
Mr Rammer poster,
left politics at the end of the nineties
and leaped into the business wells as
you know,
what?
Thanks to his influence and his good
relations with governments around the
posts that became one of the wealthiest
men in sub Saharan Africa.
His car,
unfortunately is estimated to be close
to half a billion dollars.
Well,
the fact is that this new president has
promised in new dawn and he has said
that his policy will prioritize
balancing public accounts,
attracting investments,
fighting corruption is mostly with South
Africa,
is open for business.
Of course,
these are already facing some problems.
In March,
the National Assembly approved the start
of the process to change the
constitution in such a way that the
governments can express,
create the lands of the white population
without any compensation,
and if they do carry this out,
investments are certainly not going to
come to the country.
In fact,
they're going to flee in the end.
Only time is going to tell if this new
government will succeed in getting South
Africans and joined the lions that are
awakening for if the country will
continue on its path towards the abyss.
But now it's your turn.
Do you think your country's own
government is fighting enough against
corruption?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you did enjoy this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did,
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcasts tape
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching.